- How many fucking times
do I have to tell you,
I don't care.
- Daily offender, crazy EastEnder.
Sully, how can I help you, fam?
You're looking mad stressed.
- Next time you speak to your baby mum,
tell her, tell her.
I'm gonna be way calmer on the phone,
way calmer.
Composure, lads, com-po-sure.
- Mode said if he gets sent down,
Leighton takes over.
- 18 fucking years, G.
That is heavy, bro.
- [Jean] We are the news, isn't it?
Modie's gone down.
- [Sully] Get some breakfast, man.
Cheers.
- Yo, man! Big man.
(chatter in the cafeteria)
Hey, someone's looking
like they're going home!
- Yeah.
- (laughs) Sully, big Sully, you know?
- Some more beans, yeah.
- To see Modie.
- To see--
- I just want them to see
what you're about to do?
- Mm-hmm, yeah, you stand up.
- What are you going to do?
- Stand up.
- What are you going to do? Huh?
Sully, don't tell me
because you're getting out on Friday,
big bad Sully, you now!
- Don't fucking touch me--
- Don't tell me 'cause
you're getting out on Friday,
you're gonna come here and
just have a conversation.
I'm disappointed.
- Get your fucking guys out my cell block.
- Oh Sully!
Sulla-ha-sully!
You ain't going nowhere on Friday.
Fucking pussy!
- Oi!
(shrieking)
- Shhhhh! Fucking pussy now!
(screaming)
(whistle blowing)
(intense music)
- [Paramedic] It's okay.
(Modie groaning)
- Come on.
(phone buzzing)
- Easy, brother. We good.
- Fucking lay down!
Don't fuck him up!
(screams)
- Eh, Get up. Get down, (muttering)
- Oi, get back! Oi, get back, get back.
- Ain't fucking around, lad.
- Hey, open that up!
- Let's go, Let's go!
(wheels squealing)
(group laughing)
- Yo, Modie's escaped!
- [Man] What?
- It's right there!
- Oh fuck...
- Oh shit...
- So what,
Does that mean Modie's coming back?
- What do you mean back?
To run the fields, no man.
- That's definitely happening.
(clicks tongue)
- Quick question.
Kind of disappointed still.
Before I went in jail,
we had Tomahouse on the fucking ropes.
All of a sudden I go away,
(snaps fingers)
Boom.
Tomahouse are running their fucking men.
I'm hearing them have got a new supplier,
and I want to meet him.
- He won't want to meet.
- That's strange.
I didn't hear you ask him just then,
- He's jumpy. He won't want to meet.
- Well, he's going to be jumping,
off the side of a fucking cliff,
if you don't organize it.
Set it up, Jean.
Look, got to go.
Fleet in visit.
Wanted man as such.
- One more thing--
- No, no.
- I need you to do,
- Just give me my money man.
- Yeah. Listen to me bro, yeah?
Listen to me.
(laughs)
when you help me get Sully,
you'll get your money, bro.
I know you, I know you well,
and there's no way that
you're going to miss
when we fucking smoke Sully
- All right, chill. Chill.
- There's no way
- Bro--
- You're going to be there with me,
front and center,
live and direct.
That's what I'm talking about.
My guy, my guy!
(laughs) Oh, ha-ha.
My guy.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Sully!
(gun firing loudly)
- Sully! You're fucking dead!
- Hey, hey! Fuck, get up!
(gun firing loudly)
Sully, yo Sully, get up man.
- Yo, for Chr--
- Come on!
(gun firing loudly)
(angry yelling)
Fuck!
Oh!
- She's the supplier.
- Me and you,
need to have a conversation.
I want you to introduce me
to the people that you work with.
- Do I really have to explain this to you?
In this business,
hell, people avoid getting caught and
going to prison for 40 years.
That's by being clever.
They know me,
and they trust me.
They don't know you.
And they won't meet you.
- Well, you and I, are going
to change that, aren't we?
(hip-hop plays in background)
(loud laughter)
- Eh, oh!
Who's that on the phone though?
Is that my sister?
- Be careful--
- Let me talk to her.
- Yeah, I've got to go.
- Yo, (mumbles) guess who
is this, guess who is this.
- Listen don't say your name,
we don't know who's listening.
- It's your baby brother!
- What the fuck did I just say?
- Listen, chill man, I'm
not going to say my name.
Yo, I-- are you seeing the news right now?
My face is everywhere,
saying I'm public enemy number one.
- For fu--
- Armed, and fucking dangerous!
- Yo, give me the phone,
and stop fucking about, lad!
- (laughing) look, I'm going to
pass the phone to your man now,
'cause he's tweaking right now and--
(somber music)
- (grunts in pain)
- He's got an issue with his eye.
Yeah, he's managed to get some
boiling water on his eyeball.
And, um, it seems to have become infected.
It's caused him a lot
of pain and irritation.
- I think, I think we're--
- (gasping) fuck, what did I just say?
- No, no, no, just, there we are.
Here, hold that up, okay?
Right, there you are.
- What, is that going to fix my eye?
- (stammering) Your eye,
I'm going to give you something for that.
The important thing,
is to keep it clean.
Clean it with this,
before you go to bed,
when you wake up in the morning,
and then take these drops,
four times a day,
five drops each time, right?
- Right, and this is
going to fix it, yeah?
- Aye, fix you fine that then.
I have seen eye injuries a
lot worse then that, okay?
- And what, you fixed them, you know like,
you restored their vision and that?
- Yeah, yeah, mostly, more or less.
- More or less, Christ, fucking life.
(hip-hop plays on the radio)
why are you taking so fucking long?
Jesus fucking-- oh my God. (groans)
(cars honking)
What do you want?
What the fuck!
(tires screeching)
Yo! Yo!
- [Policemen] Police! Police!
- Ah, fuck, fuck, fuck!
- I need you to listen to me--
- Ah! I'm doing it.
I'm doing it!
- Hands on the wheel,
Fuck, don't shoot.
(frustrated grunting)
- Stay calm!
All right shoot him!
(gun firing loudly)
- Shotgun, in.
- [Woman] Shots fired, shots
fired, and I have urgent--
(helicopters flying in distance)